[Music]
foreign
the Press preview a first look at what
is on the front pages time then to see
what's making the headlines with the
daily mirrors associate editor Kevin
McGuire and the Daily Mail columnist
Sarah Vine he'll be with us from now
until just before midnight welcome to
both of you so to the front pages then
let's start with the Metro they're
Splash so where are you really from
referencing the comments made by
baroness Hussey to the domestic violence
campaign and gozie Fulani who is black
and British daily mail runs with the
same story it's headline meet and greet
that sparked a royal disaster
likewise The Daily Express Prince
William condemns godmother in Palace
race round the telegraph points out that
strikes of one form or another will be
taking place every day until Christmas
according to the eye the former head of
the covet vaccine task force named Kate
Bingham has criticized the government's
handling of the development of new jobs
for any future variants
research seen by the guardian has found
that 70 percent of England's water
industry is owned by Foreign entities
the financial times carries criticism
from the European commission and the U.S
treasury secretary over an apparent
loosening of Twitter's moderation
policies under its new owner Elon Musk
and on the front of the sun singer
Chesney Hawks his performance at the
England Wales World Cup halftime show is
reflected with the headline I am the one
and only three Lions mascot
well a reminder by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
torah's newspapers while you watch us so
let's go straight to our guests then
Kevin McGuire and Sarah Vine welcome to
both of you and Sarah should we go
straight to your front page The Daily
Mail which sums it up with the with the
headline there meet and greet that
sparked a royal disaster
yeah I mean this is a huge story and
it's a huge story for a number of
reasons I mean you know what Susan
Hussey said was incredibly insensitive
and rude in a way that only very Grand
people can be
um and you know whether or not it was
racist I think is debatable but it was
certainly like I said very rude and
insensitive but the reason it's such an
interesting story and such an important
story is of course because we've got all
these accusations against the royal
family of uh sort of institutional
racism from Harry and Megan and so of
course this sort of uh you know this
will this will give fuel to all of that
and it will stir things up which is why
I think I think Prince William has been
so
um
quick in denouncing it and why Susan
Hussey has been uh dispatched so swiftly
I mean she's been a pretty sort of uh
staple part of royal royal kind of you
know uh cotery for the last 60 years and
she's just suddenly gone but I think
they're very keen to you know be seen to
be acting swiftly and decisively on this
it's it's it's it just it it just
presses an awful lot of buttons for the
royal family yes and very close to the
late Queen lady hussy
um and uh 83 years old held an honorary
Royal post under King Charles but Kevin
certainly the the conversation does make
extremely uncomfortable reading does it
not if I quote from some of it well you
must know where you're from I spent time
in France where are you from no but
where'd you really come from where do
your people come from and so on
um you know what what are the
difficulties as uh as Sarah pointed out
there for the royal family after a
conversation like this becomes public
leg
yeah I think I think it is rude and
incentive insensitive as uh Sarah said
but uh maybe two but it's it's certainly
racist uh I think without question
because it seemed she had difficulty
accepting a black Britain was a black
Britain wanted to trace and place her
elsewhere but the problems for the royal
family those Meghan Markle Prince Harry
allegations of racism never fully went
away after they were aired in the Opera
wintry interview they didn't say you
know they were pointing the finger at
but it was there I remember the very
rare public uh comment on an area such
as this
the Prince of Wales as he is now William
denied the royal family was racist when
he was asked during a a walkabout but
this will raise raise concerns that uh
elements were are certainly some
courtiers were and that there was
something to Meghan markle's um
complaint and she
she Meghan Markle could be a ruthless
social climber and possibly unpleasant
at times herself and some of her
accounts weren't uh fully accurate but
she could also be a victim of racism and
uh and snobbery too and for the uh you
know the Prince of Wales William to
slapped down his own and Sack his
godmother it shows you the extent of the
crisis now the the Royal farming itself
remember Prince uh Prince Philip the
Duke of Edinburgh many races comment
from him we always pretended they were
or said they were jokes incredibly
incense that we know now from leaked uh
papers or papers that have come a light
that the people who have of color
weren't allowed to have clerical
um you know white collar jobs in the in
the royal family until the
1960s never any suspicion around the
queen has got to be said and I think um
Prince Charles is has gone out of his
way to embrace uh people and Williams
Williams action shows the seriousness of
this and a male call call it a toxic
race route and a disaster and there we
are William and Kate have gone over to
the US Boston thought they were going to
be flying the flag uh and they'll be
cheered everywhere and I bet you're in
California there is a cackle now a
cackle saying I Told You So from Megan
and Harry yes there is a real danger um
of it overshadowing the the opposite
side of America the East Coast visit as
you say uh but in gozie Fulani um Sarah
said she felt violated and certainly
commentators subsequent to this said
describe this as part of the racial
microaggression The Daily Grind of
living in Britain for many people I mean
I I have a lot of sympathy with that
because
um I've seen it with friends of mine you
know I have one friend who's who's of
Nigerian extraction and whenever we go
to a party together everyone always
assumes he's the waiter and it's just
it's it's just they're not trying to be
rude they're really not but it's just
it's it it's just there and I think with
Susan Hussey I think partly her age is
probably a factor I mean she is 83 and I
think it's a generational thing as well
um and and and you know probably
somebody of that age of that generation
who maybe doesn't really understand how
the world's changed and how people know
our behave should probably not be in
that sort of role anyway and I think
this but this comes back to the sort of
this sort of almost this generational
route within the royal family which in
the younger more Progressive oils and
the sort of older more old-fashioned if
you like
um maybe slightly steeped in different
rules different times different sort of
sets of reverences towards Aristocrats
and people like that which just don't
really have any relevance anymore
um so I do have some sympathy with her
and I I think it must be incredibly
tedious if every time you go to a
function like that people say where are
you from that said I've eaten lots of
play most people do always ask you where
your people are from are you the
Hampshire uh Maguire's all the you know
Norfolk Maguires but I'm not sure that
was what she was doing I think she was
just
that's just a really insensitive and
just didn't understand it okay we'll
we'll move on to uh strikes front page
of the telegraph
um Kevin uh strikes on every day until
Christmas uh more unions announcing
today in fact strike action as well
today we saw
um you know
where does this go what happens next
really
yeah it's quite a wave now when you've
got much of the NHS nurses ambulance
drivers we've got rail workers you've
got posties you've got uh lecturers
we've had doc strikes uh it's pretty
pretty
um extensive and Andrea ledson a former
business secretary in that Telegraph a
piece is quoted and saying look
ministers are gonna have to roll up
their sleeves and get around the table
with union leaders and try and find a
way through this because it's been
bubbling for some time now it is because
inflation has rocketed it was 11.1 on
the Consumer Price Index more than 14 on
The Wider retail price index very few
groups that get in wage increases uh
like that living standards we saw from
many budget being absolutely crucified
so people feel feel desperate they feel
they feel abused and they're they're
fighting back and to avert it the
government is going to have to um come
up always come up with some money and
some plan there's no way around it
otherwise this will be I reckon it'll be
the biggest wave of industrial action
you know it's called wintry discontent
always goes back to 1978-79 or although
actually in that period most of the days
lost to Industrial action well late in
uh 79 when Margaret Thatcher was in
Downers Street no big engineering
strikes but it's probably the biggest
wave since
1989 1990 when I recall ambulance
workers were on strike or big train
strikes or doc strikes and and a lot of
local government strikes and some others
but it is there's no easy solution for
it but people people are desperate
that's what they are that's what this is
all about they are desperate and they
have to overcome uh workers and their
trade unions formidable legal obstacles
now to call a strike in balloting
requirements and thresholds if you're a
public service and so on and they're
passing them and when they're passing
when we've got to ask the question why
are they going on so why do they feel
they're going to risk lose using a day's
pay each time they're on strike to take
this stand and it is because they can
see what's happening to their living
standards yeah I mean it's not always
just pay is it although we have the food
inflation figures out yesterday you can
see why people you know feel like they
need more the uh the Royal Mail workers
today suggesting they're you know more
flexibility was being demanded of them
um and and the work-life balance will be
utterly disrupted if that goes through
in their view
um but do you sense a softer approach
than under Boris Johnson and Liz truss
from from this uh conservative
government Sarah Steve Barclay for
example Health secretary um tweeting
this evening I deeply regret some
ambulance staff will be taking
industrial action but then say my door
is open to discuss with unions ways we
can make the NHS a better place to work
despite saying that uh the demands are
unaffordable but you know is is there a
softening do you think
I mean I think I think that the demands
I mean they're sort of asking for 19
which I think is is is is a lot and and
and that's you know people don't get
that in the private sector and I think
that people would find that really quite
hard to swallow but I think he's right I
mean I mean a lot of a lot of people do
feel that uh certainly people like
nurses and ambulance drivers are not
really paid enough for the jobs they do
um and I think what they're trying to
what the toys are trying to avoid is
this sort of very politicized blanket
striking because obviously the unions
can see the whites of the Tory's eyes
they know they're having a hard time
they know things are difficult they know
they don't really have the funds to meet
their requirements so they know they've
sort of got them over a barrel so you
know there are two aspects to this there
is the very legitimate I think you know
question of whether we pay our emergency
staff and people who do really difficult
jobs enough probably not probably should
pay them more but also I do think the
unions are taking advantage to advantage
of the government's current situation
which is you know they're under pressure
from a lot of sides so hopefully I think
what Steve bark is trying to do is to is
to is to you know find a middle ground
which is absolutely the right thing to
do and all he can really do he doesn't
really have a choice otherwise we are we
are going to be there is going to be
someone on strike from now until the end
of the year pretty much all the time
it really affects I mean bus drivers I
mean you can't get to work anymore in
London practically yep local postee
saying to us you've got to get your
stuff in the post by the 10th of
December so there's a deadline generally
like a deadline don't they uh Sarah
Kevin stayed there lots more stuff to
come including new research showing 70
of England's water industry is foreign
owned at that and more after this break
foreign
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview with me once again Kevin McGuire
and Sarah Vine welcome back to both of
you Kevin should we get to the guardian
now which is talking about our
infrastructure and who owns it
um this time um water firms
yeah the privatized water industry in
England 70 of England's water firms in
foreign hands is that Guardian headline
I think it was actually 72 17 countries
Qatar Abu Dhabi China all have steaks in
Thames seven Trenton and control it it
was sold off uh back in the Thatcher era
uh to create what H2O owners as they put
it open lots of small shareholders would
take the chair as well it's just big
Pension funds investment companies have
taken them over and it's one of the
reasons and it's a research by soas
University of London so there's just a
lack of accountability when you're
complaining about the lack of investment
in your your area or
um a household waste been pumped in the
rivers or into into the sea well the
ultimate owners of that company are a
long long way away and it's very hard
for you to influence them it was a
disaster though what is a Public
Services you'll be publicly publicly
publicly owned publicly run publicly
controlled and then publicly accountable
yeah um lack of accountability um Sarah
or just lack of money in this country to
provide the investment to make to make
this domestic owned
well I don't know I don't I think I I'm
personally I'm really shocked about this
I didn't have no idea this was the case
I mean I think all of us you know my
water company is Thames water and
they've only just lifted the hose pipe
band even though it's been pouring with
rain for the last you know they just are
incompetent
um but it's like it's it's like um the
Chinese having steaks in nuclear power
stations I mean these I think Kevin is
right here you know these are publicly
the the British services and they should
really be you know run for by by British
by British companies by the state I mean
they they shouldn't be owned for profit
by countries like Qatar it's just
Bonkers
um but I mean if it happened in the in
the night in the 80s you know I don't
know I don't know how you extricate
yourself from that is that the Daily
Mail ceravine calling for
renationalization
[Laughter]
I just think but I do think it's great
don't you think I mean I I don't know
maybe I'm wrong maybe it's it's the way
forward I have no idea but I just these
are not countries that I would
particularly want us to be associated
with you know we we you know I don't
like the fact that we do lots of
business with the Saudis for the same
reason you know I don't really want them
earning infrastructure services that are
vital you've got 10 seconds 10 seconds
Kevin
it's a cross look if you look at rail
you've got China you've got term french
companies German Dutch Spanish all
running trains how many companies you
haven't you haven't got is really the
British state
well both of you thank you very much
indeed we plan to talk about Fleetwood
Mac star Christine McVie um who's uh
who's died as well but we'll do that
next time but uh thank you both very
much indeed for now we'll certainly
reflect on her and her achievements and
her writing skills